foreign so hello everyone a very warm
greeting to one and all my name is
srigori Krishna Kumar and I would like
to welcome you all for the third webinar
on microbiome in Health and Wellness
hackathon
so for those of you who are new to this
the series of hackathon webinars this
November we are organizing a hackathon
on microbiome in health and wellness to
provide students with a platform to
Showcase their Innovative mindset of
problem solving in this hackathon each
student will have the opportunity to
develop a mini project around the
hackathon topic form a team with at
least two other students and compete
against others for mentorship support
from established companies and long-term
interest from the business community and
the applications of hackathon are in the
fields of obesity and Precision
Nutrition Innovation and beauty products
and pregnancy
during the first webinar we focused on
the topics that we will be covered
during the one Workshop or microbiome
business here we discussed what the
hackathon is all about what kind of
opportunities are present for the
students and popular research
Publications that will provide ideas for
students participating in the hackathon
during our second webinar we focused on
the week two Workshop topics that will
be focused on biotechnology here we
covered discuss topics such as
associative training resources potential
student project outcomes Technical
Resources that one can leverage using T
by info platform and translating
metagenomics Research into an Innovative
product or service
in today's webinar we will be
introducing the participants to the
topics that will be covered during the
week three workshops here we will be
covering topics on infrastructure for
computational analysis tools methods and
algorithms machine learning
recommendation system data visualization
and user experience
so before we begin with today's webinar
for those of you who are joining for the
first time let me also take a brief
moment to introduce you to the team
behind the program we are a us-based
bioinformatics company who's working
with multiple academic and Commercial
collaborators to develop easy to use
analytical tools and our mission is to
make bioinformatics more accessible
as part of the hackathon students will
have access to the omix logic training
that has been completed by over 24 000
participants from 187 countries in over
300 workshops and due to this fast
growth our team is working with local
and Regional coordinators that are
helping refine local program Logistics
and adapting them to the needs of
students and researchers around the
world and this training has been
completed by participants in six
different specialization tracks that
includes oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine Neuroscience data
science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omix data
analysis
as a part of the hackathon students and
researchers will also have access to the
omics logic resources but how does it
help Advance bioinformatics teaching
women's logic is a portal for practical
and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics it takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear path of the
Bloom's taxonomy pyramid and no matter
what the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omics logic is a
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
set and introduction to basic coding
languages like R and python or even
beginning a data analysis project
this also comes with an access to
omixologic courses which include courses
on bioinformatics Precision medicine
multi-omics
such as genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics and epigenomics data
science that includes bioinformatics
using R and python as well as
cheminformatics and use an example
projects of different fields which you
could learn from and replicate for your
research work and the users will be
given directions to access the T by info
platform for bioinformatic processing
and Analysis of data the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run bioinformatic
pipelines different stages of analysis
are performed in different sections on
this multi-omics platform
so to get access to all of this you need
to first sign up on the omnis logic loan
portal before that let me walk you
through a brief demo on what a completed
profile on the portal looks like after
you sign up
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features that you need to update
on your account that is a completed
profile will have a profile image full
name with appropriate capitalization
link to your social media handles a
brief bio about yourself that will
consist of your educational background
and research interests and the mentors
can view your progress under the
activity Tab and the courses you are
currently completing will appear under
the courses Tab and finally after the
completion of your course the
certificates will appear under the
certificates tab so now let us Begin by
signing up on the omics logic learn
portal
so to sign up on the portal I am sharing
the link in the chat box so please click
on the link
so that you can create an account and I
can show you the various resources that
are available on the portal so once you
sign up on the portal please put a yes
in the chat box so that I know uh we are
good to proceed so those of you who are
creating an account for the first time
you can click click on the option that
says create an account and here you will
be asked to enter your name email ID
password you can also enter using any of
your social media accounts that includes
Google Facebook Apple account GitHub
account or even Twitter
or uh for those of you who have already
signed up you can just click on the
login now option that you see here
so once you sign up on the portal please
put a yes and I can show you the various
courses and example projects that are
available on the portal
so and if you have already signed the
signed up on the portal you can put a
done in the chat box so that I know you
already have created an account
and if you're facing any kind of
technical issues you can share them in
the chat as well and our team will be
happy to help you
okay great you have two responses okay
three responses
so I'm just going to proceed ahead if
you're facing any queries you can put
them in the chat box so since I already
have an account I'm just going to click
on sign in option that you see here
so once you sign in uh you can you will
be able to view the various courses and
example projects so since let's say if
you're interested to browse through the
courses and example projects that are
related to machine learn so you could
just enter the keyword machine learning
and there you go you'll be able to see
the various courses and example projects
that are making use of the machine
learning Concepts
so now how do you update the profile
that I was explaining before so to do
that click on the tab that says welcome
back with your email ID so once you
click here you will be able to see this
option that says profile once you click
on this you'll have the option to edit
all of these details I have mentioned my
educational background and research
interest and link my LinkedIn account
and my orc ID and as explained
previously under the activity tab the
mentor and the community manager will be
able to track your learning progress and
under the courses app it will display
the various courses that you're
currently taking so for instance I have
currently involved in effect of
non-antibiotics and wet syndrome which
is a metagenomics project example
project
and once you complete any of the
projects and upload on the portal it
will be this thing here and once you
enroll for any of the programs such as
metagenomic data analysis program it
will be displayed here and after you
start taking the courses this and
complete the required assignments and
quizzes these certificates will appear
under the certificates tag so so far if
the participants are having any queries
related to how to sign up or navigating
the portal please put them in the chat
box
I'll pause for a few minutes
otherwise
okay otherwise now I'd like to pass on
the stage to
okay thank you so much for your
responses so now I'd like to pass on the
stage to Mr Elia Brodsky who will be
talking about the computer science
topics that will be covered during the
week three Workshop of the hackathon so
over to you sir
thank you sugar worry and uh welcome
everyone I will um introduce some of the
topics that we think have a lot of
promise and potential for those who are
interested to join this hackathon so
before we jump into that I wanted to
remind everyone that this is kind of an
orientation or an introduction to what's
actually coming
and a little preview of expert talks
that we have scheduled all of this
information about the hackathon who will
be speaking when they will be speaking
what are they going to be speaking about
is available on the page for the
microbiome in health and wellness
hackathon so if recovery or someone
could share that link in the chat that
would be great
and after I complete this part of the
presentation also I hope that someone
will be able to give an overview of uh
the schedule and kind of how to register
and things like that
so as rigori mentioned
um
the
hackathon for us is a little bit
different than what you would typically
think of a hackathon right typically
when people hear the word hackathon they
think competition somebody wins somebody
loses uh you know whoever wins gets it
all right
but what we're trying to do is make this
hackathon into a learning experience and
um I hope that after today's
presentation will be a lot more clear
um how and why maybe you might be
interested in the microbiome as a
technology that
um you know really brings together these
very different kinds of skill sets
computer science is the focus of today's
session but we have previously talked I
think uh briefly about the microbiome as
a field in biotechnology and business as
a an important concept to consider when
you think about the innovation
in the microbiome space and this is
aligned well with our approach in
general which is to provide Solutions
services and training in the field of
big data analytics and as a result of
this activity we have the platform that
you just signed up on and also I will
demonstrate a little bit of the platform
that you will have if you are less
familiar with bioinformatics how you can
nevertheless participate and do analysis
and kind of see what the data actually
tells us
so as a part of uh doing this work we
also interact with a network of experts
from around the world
um including Israel the US Sweden India
and many other countries and our goal is
always to bring together experts in the
field that can help us understand the
trends and Direction where that that
particular field is going and so
together with the experts for this
hackathon
we are also going to be learning
together with all of you about these
Trends about the need in the industry
about the progress that the researchers
are making and about the way that data
could be used to make that progress
accelerate that progress and and make it
more uh reliable
um in terms of that is really what we
see in the data and not just you know
hype that a lot of times unfortunately
happens in this field as well
so why microbiome the reason we chose to
select this topic for this hackathon and
in general as a topic that we feel is
important is because
um it is a recently
um kind of
uh recently uh accelerating field where
a lot of investment has yielded
um insights that are very interesting
but unfortunately a lot of those
insights still remain to be proven in
terms of the value that they produce
even though a lot of larger companies
and Industry have adopted that this
actually does have a lot of potential
and we have to harness this potential
now where has this potential primarily
been so far
primarily there's a focus on human
microbiome Therapeutics and kind of
thinking about the microbiome with
probiotics prebiotics so primarily the
gut microbiome now as you will hopefully
discover
um in this whole training period before
the hackathon and during the hackathon
itself microbiome is a technology or a
microbiome as a field and and
metagenomics as a technology has the
potential to disrupt several different
domains and in
unexpected ways oftentimes So I myself
don't come from a microbiology
background but just preparing for this
hackathon I've learned so much about the
potential of the microbiome in in
clothing in skin treatment in Aging in
balding in so many different things so I
think it's a real exciting field and
unfortunately only when something
touches so many different things
it also becomes kind of questionable as
to how those specific ideas can be
translated into actual products and here
we can see a chart that in 2018
there have been over 1500 patent
applications and I think that trend is
continuing to grow unfortunately this
chart goes only to 2019 but in 2021 I
believe that this trend is continuing to
grow so there's really a lot of
innovative ideas that could be patented
that could result in tremendous business
as well as science breakthroughs so
um what are the specific challenges in
microbiome and that we can contribute to
that we as a community we as a company
you as researchers students uh faculty
other companies maybe
um entrepreneurs what can we contribute
uh without necessarily having access to
lab space and to
um you know maybe microbiologists that
can modify strains of different bacteria
or you know design new Therapeutics and
and maybe phages that address specific
uh you know types of microbes so I think
the real benefit of microbiome as a
field is that there's a lot of data sets
that are publicly available and during
the hackathon
we will introduce you to a lot of these
uh data sets that we have been curating
as a team to highlight some of the
opportunities that we think are very
promising and then allowing our experts
to speak about the other components when
you look at these data sets what should
you consider what how can you frame your
questions in such a way that they become
interesting compelling Innovative and
addressing real challenges out there so
this availability of data I think is
really a trend that defines this field
because even surprisingly even to me
biotechnology startups rely on public
domain data sets to inform their initial
ideas and then essentially the the
company would validate a lot of those
insights that come out of the analysis
of publicly available data sets and the
same way with researchers right they
might have ideas that they also want to
validate first on public domain data
sets so there's a lot of reliance
on these data sets and the reason is
because they are done by professional
teams and professional Labs experts that
design these experiments and
Publications that then describe the
results as well right so
it's really interesting that any one of
us has access to those data sets now
unfortunately data sets are not easy to
work with and that's where engineering
computer science data science really can
play a major difference because the goal
of these disciplines is to really
translate this raw data to insights and
in addition to just insights those
insights need to be interpretable so
someone needs to understand the
mechanism of action and the biological
uh kind of context of what is being
described in this data they need to be
easily searchable
and they need to be visually compelling
and so I think those are the things that
we will focus on as we think about how
to make this kind of data-driven
innovation more applicable and useful
for actual users
and that's going to be more of the focus
of you know what I will speak in a few
more slides
now
um why the hackathon as a learning
experience makes sense why this format
makes sense you know a lot of times when
we think about learning something new
There's no practical outcome and the
reason why there's no practical outcome
is because you know you're trying to
earn a certificate or maybe say I have
completed you know some course and now I
have some skills but who knows if those
skills are real most of the time and I
think you know I've done that myself as
well we go on some online learning
platform and we watch some video we read
some text and then we get a certificate
I mean how is that necessarily learning
I don't think that there is a lot of
practical outcomes from Simply doing
that what does make that much more
practical and I think more valuable is
when you come out with a real project
and you know that could be a research
project but in this case you can really
come out with a practical solution
um and that solution really shows that
you know you have skills you know how to
apply those skills and you have done the
research from the technology to The
Domain that you're in to actual business
value that you are producing so that's
the goal of this hackathon it's a
learning experience because it will
allow you to show your creativity your
ability to overcome challenges and solve
problems
but also most importantly I think it's a
way to connect with others that can
contribute to your ideas refine them and
you know there's a a saying called iron
sharpens iron and I think in this case
uh we hope to bring together teams that
have the business
um Acumen and backgrounds that have the
data science skills and intuition and
also people that have the biotechnology
and the biology and the kind of Health
and Wellness thinking so that these are
real proposals of solutions that are
needed
okay
now how do we take these three points
innovate solve and connect and you know
start talking about the specific
challenges and opportunities with
microbiome so um I think that there's a
lot of funding that continues to be
poured into the microbiome space now as
I mentioned already
a lot of that funding goes towards
Therapeutics and things like Pro and
prebiotics and things like that so
what we are going to focus on and you
know that kind of funding um is a large
in amounts but you can see that the
number of uh these um Investments it
remains to be pretty low and that's
because it's a lot of money for only a
few products
um now if you are familiar with you know
even the stock market or or the economy
in general we know that actually small
and medium-sized businesses are the ones
that are most active and most Innovative
and they're able to you know a lot of
them fail but they are able to produce
real value and Innovation and so I think
what we are going to focus on is
pre-clinical health and wellness type
applications because we think that
there's a lot of opportunities to kind
of take this high level science and make
it practical in in the sense that it is
Data driven and proven but nevertheless
addresses the more commonplace issues
that we faced so in just a few examples
uh silver has been known uh to
um resist to have antimicrobial
properties so there's actually a lot of
metals and different types of
um you know materials that have
antimicrobial properties now this sounds
like a great idea to innovate and
understand how can antimicrobial type
material you know maybe suppress odor or
have some other good properties but we
need to remember that our skin also has
a microbiome right and and that
microbiome has a substantial effect on
the way our skin feels on the way that
our skin protects against potentially
pathogenic microbes and also how our
skin microbiome can cause things like
rashes and all kinds of other kind of
conditions that might be very unpleasant
so when we think of of you know how this
microbial
um ecosystem and an understanding of
this my into my microbial ecosystem on
our body
um can really change how we will address
these kinds of innovations that are
actually today available on you know
places like Amazon you can go and you
can find a lot of silver infused Fabric
and different kind of clothing but does
it affect the skin microbiome or does it
not right there's a lot of questions
about that and so we will have an
opportunity to address some of those
questions and kind of think about well
what is the alternative or how can or
for who maybe right um this kind of uh
product Innovation can be useful another
example that I really like is that you
know you probably have heard if you're
in the western part of the world
about many different uh metagenomic
based or microbiome based
um kind of tests that can help you pick
a right diet that can help you buy Pro
and prebiotics that are best for you and
things like that but you know as you
have more and more of these kinds of
tests and and they say that well we do
meta transcript on link where we do
manage genomic or we do just amplicon
sequencing this is an opportunity to
start thinking about well where is the
opportunity for one of these companies
to do things differently innovate and
capture the market because they're all
struggling to grow Beyond a certain
number of users and so those business
problems are related to also you know
how the public perceives the actual
benefits of microbiome sequencing or
understanding your microbiome or um you
know how to maybe link it to specific
phenotypes if there is a direct link so
those are some of the questions that we
can really focus on and I think the
important part here as we think about
solving these challenges is being able
to connect to experts that can guide us
provide us with Clarity and help us
eliminate kind of questions that are
already explored and will not lead to
anything specific
and the ultimate goal as I mentioned is
to actually build
um something and
you know the final product that you will
have is something that you will be able
to take with you for a much longer time
that will continue to be relevant Beyond
you know a a certificate that you can
simply add to your resume and I think
it's really an opportunity to develop
something that you have validation you
have feedback from experts that are in
the industry that have tried to innovate
in this space that do research in the
space right and really know how to
provide something that is very valuable
and that is something that you can
directly take
and continue working on it even you know
potentially raise money for it because
um there's a lot of investment in the
space you can continue doing research um
on that topic and you can also continue
to build out products based on your
understanding of what challenges exist
with the data
so again we have these three topics that
we will cover in the microbiome obesity
Precision Nutrition for the gut
microbiome skin aging and Beauty for the
skin microbiome and then pregnancy and
femtech for vaginal microbiome now
there's a lot of overlap you will find
for example that in the femtech world
women are treating different uh you know
micro microbiome related conditions with
pre and probiotics that are taken orally
so they are gut microbiome based and you
also find that some gut microbiome
changes can affect things like balding
and and dandruff and and that's also you
know skin related but also gut related
so really this microbiome related space
there's a lot of overlap between these
different areas but in each one of these
areas there are also specific things to
consider as we think about you know what
is knee needed who is it needed for and
what is innovative and different about
it
obesity and Precision Nutrition is I
think the most
um kind of widely known uh topic where
we have
um one primary Challenge and again you
will hear from experts on this as well
but I just want to give you kind of a
preview of what that will cover so um
one important consideration here is that
anyone can diet right I mean if you stop
eating and I stop eating we're going to
lose a lot of weight right away the
problem isn't that the problem is
sustaining that weight loss over time
and addressing specific challenges to
different individuals at different age
ages and and conditions of their body
that will really help them to lose
weight in the long term and feel good
about it at the same time so so that
will be something that we will talk
about in that session as I mentioned
skin aging and beauty
is a huge industry
um traditionally of course more women
are focused on that but today even men
are aware of their looks and and kind of
how their skin
um and comfort of their skin is uh
related and that's why you see and you
know Silver Line clothing and and that's
why you're seeing all kinds of uh you
know questions about whether this kind
of lotion or that kind of lotion is
appropriate for what type of skin so I
think a really interesting topic uh with
existing products on the market already
that are claiming you know that this
works and and how it works exactly so I
think a very interesting topic there as
well
finally pregnancy and authentic you know
uh all of us uh men women we all um have
a a link to
um you know pregnancy and to um uh you
know childbirth
um so I think fertility
um you know is a big business but also
there's a lot of um other kind of things
that we might not necessarily you know
uh hear about or understand I think that
we recently spoke to an expert who is
actually working on a company in that
field and she was telling us about how
you know women a lot of times don't know
um how the microbiome factors in to
these decisions that they have to make
and you know a lot of clinicians don't
know and really Health Care is starting
to become a lot more focused on
prevention
um rather than treatment and I think
this is a huge opportunity because the
microbiome just by its property is
something that can establish a certain
condition in its environment and I think
that
um you know this is a very um specific
kind of a challenge where those kinds of
preventive and long-term benefits are
extremely important for the outcomes
all right so let's briefly uh kind of
talk about the major focus of today and
the major focus of today is what are the
specific skills that you have to know or
what are these data science computer
science and engineering type solutions
that we think are most promising in this
field
so as you know one of the major
um kind of ways that we can study the
microbiome is through sequencing and the
reason for that is because culturing
bacteria right we could culture bacteria
but unfortunately only like one percent
of all bacteria could be cultured in the
lab and when it is cultured in the lab
it is now in isolation and because it's
in isolation we don't understand how
those microbes actually interact with
the other microbes in the microbiome
because microbiome is like a community
that works together and so sequencing
allows us to actually
understand what kinds of bacteria we
have and potentially what kinds of um
you know enzymatic or active compounds
they produce and and that's a very
important kind of a technology that
really for the first time ever allows us
to see what is happening in the real
time so so uh you know what's important
to understand well what's important to
understand for some of these techniques
is that they work in different ways
um they they have different methods of
sample preparation and we'll talk about
that as well because really how do you
sample skin microbiome you know
um you know for example we can have an
oily skin and you know then you can have
a swipe and understand what's in the
swipe but what if you have dandruff I
mean how do you understand
the micro microbial community
of a dry skin right so so there are ways
to do this this there are techniques to
do this we'll talk about that um during
the hackathon preparation as well and
you know when you sequence
um now the challenge becomes well you
know a lot of this data that is uh
prepared in a certain way after it is
sequenced it has very specific
properties and the property really is
that you have
um different approaches to process that
data preparing it for analysis and the
preparation of the data for analysis is
critical for your analysis to be
accurate and for it to be clear and
beyond that as I mentioned we have
different methods of data generation
that perhaps result in a challenge of
monotonics integration because we're
talking about you know the microbiome
and maybe the metabolo or maybe even the
host gene expression right so there's a
lot to think about as we approach this
kind of data now there are some standard
tools in the field and it's important to
understand what these tools are I mean a
very kind of popular package of tools
called chyme or chime is a collection of
tools designed for 16s ribosomal RNA uh
and and you know there are other things
that we should think about because
really just beyond these standard tools
that we have to understand because they
address very specific uh noise issues
and very specific reproducibility and
accuracy issues we also need to think
about well what other methods are out
there for example there are 16s
ribosomal RNA hyper variable region
amplicon there's also just the full 16s
ribosome RNA amplicon there's full
metagenomics where we try to assemble
individual genomes that has met a
transcriptome
transcriptomics where we try to
understand what are the genes that are
being produced by AI these bacteria by
these
organisms there's metabolomics which
looks at active compounds they're not
proteins but they're metabolites so
smaller kind of active compounds that
are being generated and produced and
there are methods to do that like
um you know lcms and msms there's gene
expression studies again how dust our
body the host respond to the changes in
the microbiome for example if we talk
about inflammation a major Topic in the
leaky gut or uh you know maybe even skin
rashes right how do we connect the
changes in the microbiome or the
expression changes not the composition
changes but expression changes to how
our body reacts and even genomics you
know what kind of genomic or genetic
properties kind of tend to fall in a
specific type of a microbiome in
addition to that there are three
additional things that I think are very
important from a computer science kind
of perspective one of of them is machine
learning so why machine learning well
the reason why machine learning is such
a big deal is because these data sets as
they grow and when they grow that means
we have better representation of
different individual types we also need
more complex and kind of sensitive
methods to find and extract patterns
an important part here is also
visualization right and visualization I
think is not just having a plot today
visualization is much more connected to
the data because it is interactive and
it allows us to quickly search and find
patterns that we know how to interpret
so a lot of it is about connecting
different sources of data together and
then finally cloud computing so why
cloud computing well one of the main
reasons cloud computing is such a big
deal in this case is because once you
produce something you would like it to
be usable by many different individuals
on demand without having to put upfront
investments into Hardware that is
necessary for these kinds of
applications to operate so environments
on the cloud a lot of which are provided
free of cost initially are going to be
very useful for prototyping and
designing something that works today on
a small population and then events
actually can be used by larger and
larger users without that upfront
investment but of course the cloud
technology is nothing more than Simply
Having that accessible Hardware
elsewhere and so understanding the
process of accessing different compute
resources different database type
resources and even different kinds of
you know storage data storage resources
are going to be very important to be
able to produce something that is
actually valuable
a good example of that is an
understanding of how recommendation
systems are working today and what kind
of innovation could be added to them
when we think about the information that
the microbiome can provide for things
like activity tracking Precision
Nutrition and things like that and a
good example here is this this is an
example from a another hackathon that a
team of students actually made where
they made a food recommendation system
that relies on machine learning
that asks questions about your
preferences your diet choices and things
like that and recommends similar Foods
through this recommendation system so
what you will see is that a lot of the
approaches are to find a similar
comparable or alternative right so for
example let's think about
users that let's say have different
kinds of microbial communities in their
gut well and I D in an ideal world for a
machine learning recommendation system
what you can say is once I identify a
group of similar individuals I can say
well this is what I know about this
group and this person is new how could I
recommend to them something that works
for the rest but if you think about the
microbiome that becomes kind of
challenging because even describing what
groups are identifying how to match
those groups and then understanding what
do those groups actually mean are all
areas where Innovation is critically
needed
so here's a a brief example of you know
how this recommendation system actually
works uh you can see that you know you
kind of type in so again you can start
thinking about uh you know how this idea
could be further developed into
something that incorporates the
microbiome
um and kind of helps us think about a
user using something like this
um again you know maybe once or maybe
continuously you know using it to
actually get some ideas about you know
what they
um what they might find useful so again
I am not necessarily the expert in all
of these things uh but I do want to
share
um how um you know a lot of these
um
things
um are you know ideas that I think
everyone will learn from by listening to
experts in the field and I am pleased to
know that there's a whole panel of
experts that are going to be presenting
um from you know technology backgrounds
like sequencing from industry uh
Innovation perspective like even
investors that have invested in this
field and can tell you what has worked
what hasn't worked and why
um experts in computer science and
machine learning that have built such
recommendation systems and also
researchers that continue to identify
insights that maybe are sitting on the
shelf and did not find an opportunity to
be translated into a real product so a
lot of interesting experts that we you
can learn from during this hackathon
now primarily this hackathon is for our
partner program so as you probably know
uh Pine biotech is working with academic
Partners around the world in Africa in
the US in India and we develop these
relationships with universities because
universities are kind of The Gatekeepers
for students to be introduced to these
kinds of topics and so we would like
them to have a clear understanding of
how you know these these ideas that they
learn about could also be translated
further and so this specific opportunity
is for the partner University program
but we are also looking for additional
Partners so if you are here today and
you are a faculty and you teach students
in some way we would love to talk to you
after this webinar to identify a way for
us to work together
you know I think we can bring a lot of
value to this kind of
bioinformatics training with outcomes
with practical outcomes like this
hackathon and we're also looking for
your ideas and your contribution to help
shape programs like these as we continue
to grow this partnership program
now as already mentioned you know this
is not something that we just recently
started I mean we have been doing this
for several years and we have over 24
000 participants on our portal across
162 countries many different
universities that we have worked with
and and I hope that you know through
this hackathon and through this
partnership program we would be able to
connect as well and and continue to grow
this um uh this industry together
so if anyone would like to speak about
that I welcome you to reach out to me uh
personally especially if you are in the
US but also uh the Director of Business
Development uh Mohit mazumdar you can
email us on these email addresses that's
probably the best way but also we
welcome you know you to connect with us
on LinkedIn uh of course you know find
us on social media and would love to
talk to you more about all of this
so um with that I would love to pass
this on to talk a little bit more about
how to register and secure your
participation
um in this
uh hackathon
oh thank you so much sir or if you have
any questions yes sorry I forgot if you
have any questions I'm also um you know
here to answer any questions that you
might have
um about
um you know any of the topics that I've
talked about
foreign
so if you have any queries please put
them in the chat we'll pause for a few
minutes
all right uh to start with the hackathon
registration details I would like to
pass on the stage now to miss first the
marketing manager at find marketing so
over to use function
thank you so much uh SRI gauri so let me
find ways to share my screen in just a
moment
could you please cancel me if you can
see my screen
yes perfect it is visible
perfect
um so hello all my name is parshner and
I am the marketing manager here at
buying biotech so I'll be quickly uh
walking you walk you through the
registration part and the resources
which you'll have have access to when
you enroll for this hackathon and then
some important days uh dates or which
you all should know before joining the
hackathon and about the workshops also
so uh moving next talking about the uh
talking about the access to different
resources which one would have access to
after the enrollment uh into the
hackathon is number one is they will
have access to the t-bio info server the
platform through which one can analyze
interpret uh their data sets fine then
they will have Cloud infrastructure and
custom dashboards for uh
customized visualization statistical
analysis or statistical interpretation
of the data sets on which they are
working
second is they will have a premium
license to omix Logic coursework for
basic to Advanced Training where one
could find courseworks on multiple
topics for example
genomics for example transcriptomic for
example metagenomics bioinformatics or
computational biology or if one is
interested in data science or are in
Python languages Etc so one can get
started from Basics to Advanced learning
in some different specialization tracks
also then next
one would have or the access to the
Practical example projects data sets
case studies so related to the
microbiome based clinical research study
so these are some of the example
research projects which we have
highlighted right now uh one is on role
of high fat diet uh on obesity hfd
versus childhood mice second is effects
of dietary fiber intake on gut
microbiome third is gut microbiome this
biosis effect on
non-antibiotics and red syndrome so
these are some of the uh like example
research projects on which our team have
worked on and it's being published on
our obix logic loan potent and you can
go through and learn more about the
different applications on which our work
hackathon is revolving around about
obesity procedure nutrition Innovation
and beauty products and then pregnancy
now moving further uh our hackathon is
going to commence from November 1 and it
will get end on November 28th so the
main event is starting from November
23rd uh till November 28 before the main
event we are organizing a three-week
workshop and these workshops are led by
expert industrial academic uh uh these
uh expert industry and academic sessions
so the first week is devoted towards the
microbiome business where we'll be
covering some of the topics as mentioned
uh microbiome health and wellness
monitoring supplements in Wellness
Technologies omics and microbiome
sequencing B2B bioinformatics for health
and then less b2c recommendation system
so the first week would be devoted
towards the microbiome business then the
second week Workshop will be devoted
towards the applying biotechnology where
we'll be discussing about gut microbiome
including health diet skin microbiome
Beauty comfort and aging vaginal
microbiome pregnancy and femtic
then the third week Workshop would be
devoted towards the applying computer
science where we'll be discussing about
the infrastructure for computational
analysis tools methods and algorithms
machine learning recommendation system
data visualization and user experience
so in all these Workshop we will be
including access to the life expert
sessions one-on-one mentors and training
sessions for developing applications
based on biotechnology Innovation
through research that would eventually
help you out in uh like creating a
further MVP or creating inventors pitch
for the hackathon now moving further as
we discussed at the main event is from
November 23rd till November 28th there
would be certification and recognition
for those who be selected and then there
will be cash pricing and also there are
some of the investors which we have
invited for our hackathon so there could
be a funding opportunities also for the
teams which have been enrolled as a
participant and they'll further move by
creating the MVP Etc now uh who will
speak
who will speak in our hackathon and who
will be the judges so we'll have a
different
judges uh in our hackathon one is from
one is Raya Khan and she's the
co-founder of Life Norm then we have Dr
shubhi Khan and founder and CEO of onco
phonomics then lynyana she is a investor
and she's uh she's from Life Sciences
group and band of angels then we have
Kumar Sankar and founder and CEO of
Houston Rich bio then we have
geopoliano he's uh he's from University
of Chicago Philippa Godoy uh she's from
University of Puerto Rico then Raja
verman from prima's Life Sciences and
then Dr sonali khandra uh from ikimine
so we have a expert from commercial
industry as well as academic expert for
the hackathon for judging as well as for
speaking and providing you with expert
like training sessions
now these are some important dates which
one should remember so the registrations
would get close uh this week like
upcoming week October 31 Monday and then
hackathon training program will start
from November 1 till November 22 and the
hackathon main event would be uh like
from November 23rd until November 28th
so this was briefly about the um
registrations the resources one would
have access to and the important days
which you all need to remember so these
are the details if anyone is having any
queries uh regarding a hackathon and
like the registration part
Etc so they can inquire uh on
marketing.com and the number right now
uh like flashing on the screen that is
9876134120 it is active on WhatsApp also
you can get you can ping me on Whatsapp
also so
um this was about the registration uh
now
I'll just quickly uh show you
uh srigori could you please confirm if
my screen is still visible
yes we are seeing your presentation at
the moment
okay I'll just stop my uh screen and
again share it
okay uh now can you see the page
February yes we can see the page
perfect so uh last thing which I would
like to discuss is about the
registration cost
for the hackathon so we have divided the
registration cost into three different
categories if an individual student is
interested to be a part of the hackathon
so the registration cost for that
individual student is dollar 100 USD for
a group of students of like in a group
it means four to five minimum students
should be there the registration cost is
dollar 300 and those who like and those
uh with whom we have collaborated are
partner universities uh the registration
cost is 100 again four to five members
per team so as you scroll down you will
see three different buttons so if an
individual student who is interested to
enroll for the hackathon can simply
click on this button and he or she will
be redirected to the payment page and
you can simply uh like add your details
over here and proceed with the payment
checkout so uh this is the same process
which you will follow for a group of
students uh and then for the partner
University payment checkout also so this
was briefly about the hackathon
registration the resources and the three
week Workshop which we'll have uh
starting from November one and ending on
November 22. so uh if anyone is having
any queries related uh to the
registration part or resources please
feel free to Ping in the chat box and
I'll be there to help and guide you
thank you over to you sugary
thank you so much sparsh so does anyone
have any queries we will pause for a few
minutes so that the participants if
you're having any doubts about the
registration details about the workshop
schedules you can put them in the chat
if you have already registered for the
hackathon you could also share that in
the chat as well
we have a query that is please can I get
the PowerPoint
um or which particular PowerPoint the
PowerPoint which Elia was describing
so we'll be sharing the session
recording uh so I guess it's genomic Hub
I don't know the name of the person but
we'll be sharing the session recording
with you by tomorrow so you can go
through once again uh the recorded
version of this session yes
thank you so much parsh and we also have
few uh reaching reach out
um in the chat box
for collaboration so apart from that we
will be reaching out to you apart from
that uh art does anyone have any queries
otherwise we are good to end today's
meeting
uh Stephen has raised his hand so yes
Stephen you can unmute yourself and ask
as well
uh it looks like we are not able to hear
you it is still showing mute
so if you could please unmute yourself
then
we'll be able to answer your query
otherwise you can share it in the chat
box as well
and I can take up your query
it looks like uh let me see
okay uh could you please give access to
Stephen to unmute it looks like
foreign
oh
okay um the question is what what
happens if you win is that the question
no
the question was uh
yeah go ahead
I registering as a single as a single
student uh-huh and uh you go on to to
apply for uh the competition as still a
single student does it reduce uh the
chances for winning if if you apply that
as a single student it's uh
same competition as well as competing
with people with groups
yes it is but we do recommend uh finding
a partner and what we can do is we can
probably help match you uh with some
additional students to work uh together
with now if you don't want to and you
want to do the whole thing on your own
you will just have these three different
aspects to address in your final
proposal which is the business aspect
the computer science aspect and the
biotechnology aspect and you know this
is a learning
process so you know we will have people
speaking about all of these aspects
helping you you know the process is that
you first kind of learn about everything
you find a data set will provide you
with some curated data sets or you can
find some on your own and then after
your initial proposal if it is um you
know of good quality we will actually
match you with a mentor to provide you
with additional feedback on your uh
project
so yes you can participate individually
we can help match you with others and it
is going to be a learning process so
hopefully uh you will gain from those
experts to refine your project before
the final submission
thank you
thank you so much
so we have another query that is
um
will the program be practical as well uh
is it Hands-On training that is a query
so special you could just explain that
um yes so the program would be both
conceptual as well as uh there would be
theoretical concept that we'll be
covering uh and for that we'll be using
t-bio info server so there are different
pipelines which will be uh teaching you
and will be uh providing you the access
so that you can run those pipelines
related to data too and kind to
pipelines so it would be both conceptual
as well as theoretically
so I hope it answer your question uh
questions
uh now for those of you that are
interested in Partnership I see several
questions about that
um yes we are
um welcoming partnership opportunities
where we're looking for partners
um and so if you can email me
um Elia at Pine dot bio or Mohit
mazumdar Mohit at Pine dot bio and we
will be following up with you in the
next few days to schedule a meeting
um discuss what exactly you have in mind
um also explain how our partnership
program works with universities uh so
yes please email and thank you sparse
for sharing your email addresses
thank you so much so does anyone have
any queries
all right genome access uh an email has
been sent so kindly check all right
we'll be getting back to you thank you
so much
so does anyone have any queries related
to hackathon otherwise you're good to
end today's meeting
thank you so much for your patience
and we would like to see you all for the
workshop as well so thank you so much
everyone have a great day
thank you everyone
thank you